a big deal for little kids and a relief
for many parents children six months of
age to under five years of age can now
be vaccinated for covet after the cdc
recommended pfizer and moderna shots for
babies and toddlers pfizer's requires
three shots at present moderna just two
now this is the last age group to become
eligible nearly a year and a half since
the first vaccines were approved joining
us now is dr ashish jaw he's a white
house covet 19 response coordinator dr
xia always good to have you here
especially today
you know a lot of parents seem to be
taking a wait-and-see attitude when it
comes to their children what can you say
to ease or concerns about getting this
vaccine for the little one
yeah good morning gail first of all
thanks for having me back
what i would say to folks and what i've
been saying is you know these vaccines
have been thoroughly tested uh millions
of children above the age of five have
gotten these vaccines they're
exceedingly safe and we expect
confidence in these vaccines to build
over time in this population and so what
i've encouraged parents to do is talk to
their family physician talk to their
their pediatrician you know the people
who take care of their kids and have
that conversation and i think over time
we're going to see a majority of parents
ending up getting their children
protected with these vaccines
how common has cove had been in the
little guys number one and number two
um if the if you've already had covet as
a child should you still get this
vaccine
yeah so
covet has been quite common in children
actually
we think maybe almost 70 percent of kids
have ended up getting infected with
covid still worth getting the vaccine
really offers an extra level a level of
protection an extra layer of protection
what vaccines do is they keep kids out
of the hospital and that's why they are
so effective and everybody deserves that
protection so even if your child has
been previously infected the strong
recommendation here is to go ahead and
get that get your child protected hey dr
jaw it's tony a point of clarification
here you said talk to your pediatrician
if you're a parent about these shots but
the pediatrician won't be the one
actually administering it is that right
no many pediatricians will tony this is
one of the things that's going to look
different in this campaign you know we
know that parents are going to want to
get their children vaccinated
in pediatricians offices look some
people will go to a pharmacy some people
will go to a children's hospital or
or
some sort of community health center but
the bottom line is i think a majority of
parents are going to want to get their
child vaccinated in their pediatrician's
office so many pediatricians are going
to be offering the vaccine
and do you see these vaccines keeping up
with variants so parents get a two shot
or three shot regimen this year and then
next year it's another shot and then
onward and upward
well we don't know i mean we don't know
the long term
play on these things so what we know is
right now
these vaccines despite the fact that we
have various variants out there are
doing an extraordinary job keeping kids
out of the hospital that's why
both cdc and fda have been so
enthusiastic the scientists have been so
enthusiastic about recommending these
things they're really making a
difference
over the long run whether the vaccines
will need tweaking or changing we'll
have to see as the virus evolves and as
the pandemic evolves
any side effects for your kids if you
get it
you know it's very similar to the to the
side effects we've seen for older kids
or for adults
that 24 hours of
some kids just you know they kind of
don't feel as well they feel tired they
don't have the same appetite
but thankfully there have not been any
serious side effects of these vaccines
and again after giving
these vaccines to millions of children
it's really reassuring to know uh that
for young kids these vaccines are
exceedingly safe
all right well i've heard that from
reliable sources my favorite grandson
luca will be getting one so dr jaw we
thank you for your time this morning
excellent thank you